bonne nouvelle pour les québécois qui
attendent toujours d'être indemnisés
pour un voyage annulé en raison de la
pandémie le gouvernement legault a fait
savoir hier qu'elle procédera au
remboursement à compter de septembre
j'en parle avec eric boisseau vice
président de l'association des agents de
voyages du québec est propriétaire de
voyages performa bonjour monsieur moi ça
nous bonsoir morin alors les
remboursements annoncés hier seront
faits par le fonds d'indemnisation des
clients des agents voyage comment ça va
fonctionner concrètement pour les
clients certains diront enfin à mon
amour et comme vous avez commencé le
topo avec ça les clients auront à
remplir un formulaire violent le fils de
protection du consommateur et le ficav
le fond d'accusations déclinera en
voyage s'enregistrer par contre ils
doivent avoir fait la demande
alors rassurant et aux tour opérateurs
grossistes avec lequel ils ont fait à
fond et apprécier le processus devrait
débuter selon ce que le gouvernement a
annoncé selon le mit les manifs je n'ai
pas débuté en septembre cette année et
se terminer en décembre
il ya déjà trente cinq mille demandes
qui ont été soumises
est ce que ses clients doivent faire
quelque chose
et qu'est ce qui arrive si ont déjà été
remboursés en partie par exemple par un
transporteur ou par un assureur privé
s'ils ont déjà été remboursés legrand 90
demandait ce qu'on a ajusté la demande
le formulaire est déjà en ligne on peut
ajuster le montant de la réclamation
versus que nous avons reçues
partiellement - complètement et la
nouvelle demande doit se faire aussi via
le formulaire et il ya des gens even for
sure que si c'était parfait il pouvait
pas le faire
je corrige l'information on peut le
faire même à partir d'aujourd'hui
frédéric lama sont ceux qui n'ont pas
que je suis leur fonds mais quelqu'un
qui a déjà fait sa réclamation est ce
qu'ils doivent faire quelque chose où il
laisse aller les choses et ça va se
régler tout seul il a ici là déjà numéro
deux doit aussi avec leur faisant vivre
en france on attend tout simplement rien
à farnham en rien le système le prix en
charge des gens mais on disait hier
l'office de protection du consommateur
disait si vous avez fait affaire avec un
voyagiste comme vacances air canada
parcs par exemple vous devriez quand
même par une réclamation auprès d'eux ça
pourra aller plus rapidement que ce
carnet c'est toute façon c'est
enfin avec ce non inertes transat air
canada et vacances air canada doivent
passer viol fournissant en premier et
advenant un co qui une partie non
remboursés ce qui serait surprenant
parce que les trois grossistes majeurs
dont on utilise beaucoup au québec ont
déjà avec l'aide du gouvernement fédéral
statut et qu'ils allaient rembourser
l'étudiant et protéger la clé la
commission d'agent de voyages par la
famine donc c'est le processus est déjà
entamée si les clients veulent que canal
plus rapidement je conçois exactement ce
que vous venez de passer via le
fournisseur en premier et de se rabattre
sur le fait qu'avant deux chiens alors
pour le futur là on commence à rêver des
voyages je pense qu'on est nombreux à
rêver les plages pour cet automne cet
hiver et qu'est ce qu'on doit savoir
avant de réserver
il faut savoir il faut valider avec ses
assurances premier lieu je vous dirai
quand à la base de tout parlez à votre
conseiller en voyage c'est de plus en
plus des points techniques avaient
validé l'entrée au pays la sortie leur
tour la quarantaine les terres c'est ce
que les hôtels font donc plusieurs
questions que votre conseiller en
voyages et formés et qu'ils maîtrisent
tous ces sujets le don pour le même prix
que ce qu'on trouve sur le web pourquoi
pas le sujet un professionnel est ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'actuellement
les assurances
on doit valider si nous sommes couverts
pour une annulation c'est pour ça que
les grossistes ont déjà émis une
certaine politique de flexibilité où on
peut acheter pour un moindre coût cette
flexibilité là je suis en voyage qu'on
va acheter exemple en février mais qu'on
veut être sûr de pouvoir partir on peut
payer un léger supplément 25 jours avant
le départ on peut annuler avec un
remboursement complet même pas un cri du
c remboursement complet ça peut valoir
la peine effectivement dans les
circonstances et côté assurance santé
est-ce que des choses qu'on doit
surveiller pour pas se retrouver avec
des mauvaises surprises
pour l'instant le gouvernement nous
sommes en niveau 3 dallaire donc éviter
tout voyage non essentiel
avec cette catégorie là les assureurs
couvrent la très grande majorité encore
là faut vérifier un parent mais la très
grande majorité de ceux qu'on connaît
couvre le
le phénomène médicales à destination
donc vous attrapez la coville ou peu
importe la région médicale vous
consultez vous serez couvert le bon est
ce que vous sentez déjà beaucoup
d'intérêt pour l'automne l'hiver est ce
qu'on devrait déjà commencer à réserver
c'est un bon moment ça peut avoir des
bons prix des effectifs les gens sont
déjà même ceux qui pensent le faire il
devrait le faire très très très bientôt
je vous dirais que la demande
généralement quelqu'un qui réserve en
septembre octobre déjà fait aujourd'hui
la demande est forte pour le pour
l'automne et l'hiver
les prix sont excellents je suspecte que
les prix devraient augmenter
incessamment car la demande est là et
l'offre est la même que le 1019 donc les
prix devraient s'ajuster un programme
c'est effectivement un très bonne
suggestion de commencer à penser à
réserver pour cet hiver pour les pour
les hoops temps et comment ça se
présente pour les croisières on en tête
encore des histoires d'horreur l'eau
début de la pandémie est ce que les gens
sont encore intéressés par les croisés
le historiquement est le phénomène de
réservations croise on a toujours été
une réservation trade avance on parle de
presque 1 1 ou 2 cette demande mais elle
est toujours là
les gens sont un peu inquiets
s'informent ya des processus par contre
je fais confiance aux compagnes trois
ans que je voyage en croisant au mois de
septembre cette année
peut-être parce que je voyageais
encourageant en 2022
très certainement merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir mais son amour est
franchement pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit